hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play lumen now this
is a game that was made by a university
group if I'm not mistaken all the
necessary information is in the
description below but it is a really
cool game from what I saw and I'm very
eager to give this a try
only three cameras done and done done
and done and done and damned done and
done so I'm on a gamepad so it's a
little bit wonky for me at the moment
but it shouldn't take too much time for
me to adjust the awakening now what this
game is about lured you off sled to do
okay I guess them I guess I'm awake now
you will need this camera take her tight
eh keys we have a long way ahead of us
so you read her head off okay if you say
so now this game is free from what I saw
and it's got a lot more policin only the
indie game that I've seen before press a
to jump that seems slightly dangerous
for a little girl but okay I believe it
I mean it is real it was very stylized
from the screenshots that I saw I didn't
actually see any video of it but mister
you know it's been a while since we last
met bad although I read you can remember
ah why you be hanging out with little
girls man what's wrong with you okay
anyway hello it's like a 3d platformer
in a creepy style my goodness hello mr.
toy soldier who is broken yurga the guy
from the main screen are you the one
talking
OOP I don't know if there's any file
damage or anything but nuke scream -
perceiving watch your step
do I need to take a picture press right
bumper a loose key true alright then
well so you know how to handle that
thing yeah oh this is really cool I love
to see very interesting and unique
stylized worlds like this I mean when it
comes to video game development it
really helps to have like a unique
mindset for what type of a game you
really really want in and have
everything kind of created in your own
oh Lord next time she she exploded and
the purple dust
I killed her oh my goodness
oh so morbid okay at least he wasn't a
shower of blood or anything but I need
to be a bit more careful so I need to
time my camera flash show that the other
one is rising as I do it so
paavo ski and then Fabio ski done and
done
got it got it okay now the primary
objective of this game I'm not entirely
sure I miss the old library waiting for
you to come back okay
why remember the warden you want to be
careful with him he's not too fond of
colorful pajamas I'm going to take him
down or he will be the one to take you
down ah do I use that big old teddy bear
coz you were kind of looking at that I'm
still like a toy you squawking your way
maybe it's time to use your camera again
ah press X to take a picture shoo Oh do
I steal it soul with my picture use the
directional pad to turn the picture whoa
whoa whoa ah oh that's still cool and
off it goes
Oh cameras more powerful than you
thought uh-oh
things are getting interesting indeed
they are sir this is really cool and
what happened to the moon up there looks
like something hit it and it exploded
but then again I'm pretty sure this is a
dream world so can I take a picture of
that monster and then steal soul or can
I take a picture of the bear and then
tip it over onto the monster I think
that's I can't take a picture now take
it yeah why does my pajamas glow red
does that mean that I'm in imminent
danger okay so nothing we need in there
okay you must find a way to get through
all right if you say so I'm trusting you
in on this one as expert a victor
Josh's who's yeah get rid of took mine
oh oh oh my goodness
oh my goodness
that's such an interesting mechanic I've
never seen anything like it in game mode
our keys uninteresting dumbstruck off
here uh is that me is that a is that me
the name of the game is lumen it looks
like a little girl hmm I wonder if I'm
dead now now there are some games
memorable that you guys probably know
about that taking advantage of camera
mechanics such as mana my personal
favorites which is Pokemon snap now if
you've heard me before you know that I
don't like Pokemon that much but I what
did I do
ah what I mean I really did enjoy
Pokemon snap just because it was like a
different exploration style game and
what am I supposed to do here there's
actually two take a picture but of what
I'm assuming it's gonna glow when I got
the right thing in my oh oh oh I did
that
you silly try any combining shake and
turning actions I can't seem to turn it
so shaken little smart very smart for it
is more dawn can i still can't turn it
I'm just gonna keep shaking it I guess
shaky shaky shaky just like I trained
every day with my shake weight I'm gonna
be able to shake don't anything what do
I do
with a present all the buttons oh oh
what oh the directional pad that's right
Oh God you got squat maybe we will make
it this time maybe what about this time
has there been other times have I failed
before al I think there is fall damage
if I go too far there's something very
etheral about having one charmed here
comes the hard part of
there's something very etheral about
having a child main character that can
very easily dine in this world of danger
reminds me a lot of limbo even though
limbo was very stylistically different
in gameplay different it was still
platformer and you still playing this
kid lost in this dream world now why he
was in that dream world is up to a lot
of debate for a lot of people but why is
for many for you okay whoa why I never
know what's around the corner
am I am i getting here was not easy huh
but getting out may be much harder then
why did you make me come in here you
douche a word of advice
yeah try not to make noise when you
won't hear them okay now I have to
comment about one thing this game has an
absolute enormous amount of work put
into it there's so much detail and
beautiful beautiful beautiful settings
here why this game was free I'm going
east apart by the place died one these
books that say lumen this game was free
I downloaded it straight from the
website and this is the type of game
even for even if Brooks stupid bird
going away again although those
fireflies seems to know where it went
what stupid bird but I mean even if this
game was like just 10 minutes long it
would be worth at least some amount of
money it's very very very well done oh
you son-of beat
I will before the got you as Elba no
Rona Mike ah I done you I done goof
oh I'm gonna get my girl killed you know
all this good to die no I can only
spread for like - ah it ain't me it's
slightly disturbing oh no fair its able
to pop up out of the floor
how's it fear hey Mike's back that
startles me don't don't don't do that
you know what I'm gonna hide until it
passes by there's extra height I don't
think anything I need to hide okay maybe
I don't need 9 whoo nice picture fish oh
okay we don't kill me don't kill me
don't kill me
you didn't Cena know this game
definitely takes advantage of the rumble
there's a lot of these things how am I
supposed to be able to get away from
them oh yeah yeah it's right there
they want my bones they want to eat me
Oh what is it it's a weird tentacle
demon thingy yeah I don't know Oh what
what rotor wing Wow
I can't move it's just there what am I
supposed to do there are a lot of them
the difficulty curve went from uh
tutorial to what how am I supposed to do
there's so many of them okay I think
this is an opening maybe okay
alright we're going for it we're going
for this gonna do it going going for it
yeah this right yeah it's right go that
way
yeah I'm over there oh oh yeah yeah you
almost got me you almost got me that was
that no zone Oh what does this do
proof Oh creepy piano diabolical
machinery will huh your folded doggies
present fish got a lightbulb her head
the lightbulb bird bird bulb light bulb
head bird just ooh okay oh well what
does that mean la bulb head bird
floating candelabras Oh imminent death
oh oh I get it they go to the last place
you were as if they were like
investigating so what do I do now wait
is this where he came in rah take that
eyeball was right
was the powernow these guys do probably
I'm still probably going to die but now
I just don't know where I'm gonna go
where am I supposed to go what am I
supposed to do
well warning ma'am gear for nog push
ever yeah huh what do we what what is
that what was that in the corner was
that the autosave I'm gonna guess do I
climb up this ladder no don't know I
don't know oh god what does that clown
turn into do I even want to know okay no
how did you say anything Oh push Oh God
not not happening all right how many how
much more I see oh yeah
what is Betty's prejudiced wish oh that
is disturbing that is creepy really cool
mechanics I mean a lot of love went into
this game Oh gather yeah that's right
you bet him dude yeah okay
I'm having a lot of fun I'm actually
having like a ton of fun playing this
game it's really really interesting oh
so cool yep all right all right you
blady bastards and you 50 pound either
loose you want to be routed through a
wall ha ha
No wouldn't want that here we go typical
Mario platformers yes whose aah
you almost had me there but you didn't
hang an x-ray picture what am I taking a
picture of the pound II dues the Slammy
whammy babies the sling song slicey news
what am I taking a picture
Oh whoa hello come here Suki what is
what am I do take your shaky shaky shaky
no how about turning Oh her some what is
that doing I can't tell just slowing him
down or is that speeding them up oh I'm
moving my thing
oh haha this is so cool why isn't this a
full-fledged game I mean this might be a
war oh that was close wait a minute
I just why didn't I jump off on the
other side
who's the point of that
alright here we go
aha nobody sir instant death instant
death didn't even try oh all this poor
little girl it's so morbid gonna fall
ski fool a my are there paintings of me
all over the upper walls I'm assuming
that's me the only little girl around
her yeah there we go
your candor is not enough Diaz you'll
never feel this library huh now need to
find a bride or souls of light ok so
it's like is that a lesson that I'm
supposed to know that like the UM the
light is symbolic of something I don't
know
turn this what what happened no I just
took a picture of that take it wait a
minute maybe I need to think bigger
jerilyn
hmm it was the only one here what oh
it's shimmering like candle in the night
huh shaky-shaky
terney were nee there we go finally okay
I didn't know why I needed to take a
picture of it in the specific position
but okay no butter wait a min what what
don't my chance what is going on I'm
actually kind of confused right now
monster doodads are still wandering down
there there's that guy who's being
experimented on for some strange reason
I wonder if there's any relation to
those guys who are made up of tentacles
and the tentacles that are popping out
of the books the obvious answer would be
oh hell yes what kind of are you
marklar yes right cuz it's still the
only thing that I can do but no no no no
Wyatt way down there is different way
down there is do okay so I turned it all
the way that way what happens if I turn
it all the way this way I can't move it
anymore okay so I mean shake a sugar Oh
what how did that happen how did that do
that I guess I shouldn't ask questions
what are you burst to babies for yeah
very few very few of me or very few of
other peoples that do I get to play
music like an octave run enough time ah
love aqua demon in time okay so what do
i do do i land on that table in there
and then up here we go
so what's all this then left left left
right left left am I supposed to
memorize after the / now for the perma
runner look the blue superdude I don't
remember it hang on e e hang on wait a
minute okay
see off right down left down right left
up I don't know
up right down right down of God
dot dot dot dot okay
let's try this wait no up right down
right oh oh god oh oh oh wait no no no
no yeah okay hang on okay maybe I can
take a picture of it and maybe maybe
then I would remember hop right down up
right down left down right Oh off right
down
oh I was doing her on down right left up
up right down down right left up up
right down left down left down right
left nose left up right down it down
left right
oh is that that's a check after all this
time so what has finally made it through
you know like a dog like you if I want
to do I could say the things that you do
I don't need a void thing we are
modified we've almost haven't done
almost have what done you think the two
can talk like me but when in fact I talk
like you see what I mean
the decision a decision is should be man
I'm so finally me have I I can't believe
someone has finally made it yeah you
have no idea how long I have belonged
here
yeah come closer and I'll take you back
home
I came out under that but before you
girls I need you to do one last thing
for me free you then
you'll be free today and I'm moving back
I promise as you can see I am trapped
and I need your powers to break free my
power oh you sure can run free me um oh
okay good I can't it's not giving me
it's not even give me the illusion of
choice here this is simply what it is
and free fall is child oh did you think
I would let your skin take a picture
what happened no no the end ah oh maybe
I could have gotten out of that and I
have no idea I don't I don't think there
was an illusion choice I think that was
leading up to something else this was
fantastic
this was um incredibly well made this
was well designed the level was
incredibly unique the narration was all
right there were some things but
obviously they're not native English
speakers and I I think this is either a
southern American team or maybe in Spain
or Portugal I'm not sure but this was
incredibly well made and it was free it
was made by University Google I don't
know if this is like an old game and I'm
way way way off base here but I think it
was relatively recent but either way
this Oh free at last
that's not good
that's not good this was fantastic this
was amazing in the level changed cuz now
the Damon Damon demon is there but that
was incredible
who's awesome who's incredibly well done
I can't wait for that I want this to be
a real game you know if there was ever
ever a project to go up on Kickstarter
something that had like a proper
playable demo to show exactly what the
development team could do this would be
the one this is the kind of proof that
people would want when they see a game
up on Kickstarter this this is amazing
this is well-made check the link in the
description for the website uh I'm it
might be old it might be new I'm hoping
it's new because if it is this is
fantastic
everybody should give this try it's
amazing I'm gonna shut up now because
I've been saying that for awhile I get
really excited when indie titles really
surprise me and really cool so yeah so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
Oh
get up
Oh No
Oh